China and India home to a third of
humanity both face a marriage crisis
that were lost for generations a mere
five years ago marriage patterns were
normal in the two countries now in India
500 year old laws and customs are being
revised to allow men to marry out of
caste out of village and out of state
while in China 50 million so-called
gronckle bear branches look doomed to
bachelor 'dom what's led to the marriage
squeeze first millions of women have
gone missing a generation ago a
preference for sons and the greater
availability of prenatal screening meant
the first Chinese couples then Indian
ones started aborting female fetuses and
only giving birth to boys at its extreme
in parts of Asia more than 120 boys were
being born for every hundred girls now
the generation with distorted sex ratios
at birth is reaching marriageable age
the result is that men far outnumber
women if China had had a normal sex
ratio at birth its female population in
2010 would have been 720 million in fact
it was only 655 million compared with
almost seven hundred and five million
men and boys fifty million surplus
husbands fertility rates then accelerate
the distortion when a country's
fertility is going down as in India
younger cohorts of people will tend to
be smaller than older ones if men are
older than women marriage as they
usually are that means there'll be fewer
potential brides than husbands because
women will have been born later when
fertility was lower then there's a
queuing effect men who can't find a wife
right away will go on looking and
competing with younger men as a result
the number of unmarried men piles up as
in a queue by 2060 there could be more
than 160 Chinese and Indian men wanting
to marry for every hundred women
this is a ferocious squeeze in countries
where marriage has always been a basic
requirement for being a full member of
society
it could be hugely harmful almost
everywhere large numbers of single men
are associated with high rates of crime
and violence no one really knows how
these two giant countries will react